what would you recommend what did you
spend um a year on clothes for your kids
oh I was I'm I'm one of those like
really proud of getting stuff for cheap
kind of people so I would go to this
consignment store that called Once Upon
a Child in the area that I live and they
would have twice a year we have like a
blowout sale where they give you a big
bag and you can fill the whole bag with
clothes for like 15 bucks wow yeah and I
could find them really good stuff like
sometimes I'd find them name brand
things that had like looked like they'd
never been worn or might never have been
worn and fill up the whole bag I'd say
probably 200 bucks a year for Five
K and then I would brag to my husband i'
be like yes I'm so good at this